welcome back the biden administration
promising to be the most transparent
ever
but already the administration is
accused of blocking media access to
migrants
illegal immigrants at the border uh not
even accused they are
not letting you get access finally today
they're caving to pressure
they're releasing video that they shot
of two texas facilities housing
migrant children so how are they really
doing when it comes to transparency and
will president biden actually admit when
he's wrong when he's wrong
as he says he is joining us now
journalist graham glenn greenwald
glenn from what you see how much are you
seeing is this a transparent
administration
no it's not even close and the irony of
course brian is that
the two most vocal media complaints
during the trump years were number one
the refusal to provide transparency the
washington post
flamboyantly adopted a new motto to
reflect its purported concerns democracy
dies in darkness and then second the
treatment of migrants at the border that
was probably
the principal argument for claiming that
trump was essentially a new hitler and
now you have these two problems
converging
where the biden administration is
refusing to allow media access where a
getty photographer said
i never had any problem under the obama
administration
or the trump administration and now
suddenly with biden administration
we can't get any access to seeing what
they're doing to people at the border
the thing we were all supposed to be so
deeply concerned about and they're not
allowing us to know
who's meeting with people in the white
house virtually which is how people
mostly
are meeting with people in the white
house because of the pandemic so they
put this huge black
curtain around what they're doing and
very few people in the media seem
particularly concerned about it
on the immigration this would blows me
away like it or not we knew exactly was
going on with president trump at the
border it was a problem was a mess
but he made adjustment fired some people
moved some people around and at the end
they pretty much had it down the
pandemic really made it a no tolerance
policy
when it was all said and done it started
happening again
they would not let cameras in but the
excuse they made glenn must have driven
you nuts even though you're all these
miles away
we're worried about the pandemic they're
worried about the reporters going in
and giving the illegal immigrants the
coronavirus
please excuse me and then when axios
gets the pictures from a democratic
congressman
henry cuellar who's being ignored by the
democratic administration
they have no more excuses
well and the other thing they claimed
gen saki claimed the reason why they
weren't allowed to allow access yet
didn't even pass the laptop
test was they were concerned for the
privacy of migrants do you think
people who are being maltreated at the
border who are being kept in cages who
have aluminum foil as blankets who have
who are being kept there way in excess
of what the law permits which is what's
happening
are concerned about their privacy or do
you think they want reporters and
they're showing
the mistreatment to which they're
subjected but again
there was enormous outrage over what was
happening at the border under president
trump it was
commonplace to hear it compared to what
was going on in nazi concentration camps
what they're doing now which is saying
oh don't worry we're going to pick and
choose the nice scenes for you and
release them and that will be the
transparency
is exactly what kind of propaganda was
constantly done in those camps
and you hear very little media outrage
there's some clamoring but nowhere near
the level we heard during the trump
years where there was a lot more
transparency at least
about what was being done to these to
these immigrants it's like if you go to
cover a story they say here are your
sound bites and here's your video go put
it together thanks i could do it myself
you brought this the other point about
who's signing the guest book when they
go to the white house
why does that matter
we need to know who it is who is
wielding influence
within the white house the executive
branch is incredibly powerful
all that power emanates from the white
house so if lobbyists are meeting with
people inside the white house or if
people who wield what influence on wall
street or who are corporate donors
are meeting with key white house
officials and then policies are being
enacted
we absolutely have a right to know who
it is who's influencing our government
which is why it's commonplace
for that kind of transparency to be
offered to know who it is who's meeting
inside the white house and they won't
even provide those kind of logs of who
is meeting virtually
so if some chief of staff of president
biden or president biden himself or
kamala harris has a meeting
with some highly influential people
who's shaping u.s policy
right now we have no way as a
journalistic force or as a public
to know who it is our government
officials are meeting with glenn are you
optimistic they're going to be some
tough questions asked at thursday's
first press conference with the
president united states
i think there will be some questions
about the the crisis at the border
because
that kind of hypocrisy is too glaring
even for them
but when you look at everything that the
biden administration is already doing
things like appealing the
the prosecution of julian assange who
brought more transparency to the u.s
government
than anybody else the record that
they're that they're claiming that they
will support and the actions that
they're pursuing are so wildly disparate
that it ought to be a very hostile press
conference
and i doubt it will be that glenn always
great to see you always great to get
your opinions thanks so much
good to see you brian all right